salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous faisons un focus sur un
point en particulier du cerveau dans
l'épisode précédent vous m'avez demandé
si l'être humain était vraiment
prévisible c'est le sujet du jour
bienvenue dans matière grise
[Musique]
e
on rit
français
dans cet épisode nous allons vivre
quatre expériences expérience une votre
corps vous trail expérience de devenir
la voix de marquion expérience 3 c'est à
vous expérience 4 votre corps et il
prévisible le tout avec la présence très
appréciée de ludovic b
aujourd'hui on va parler de cul berlin
10 mhz ce nom très bizarre et la
définition de la lecture micro
musculaire ou plus généralement des
micromouvements musculaire la première
fois que j'ai pu entendre parler de ça
c'est bien la magie et de mentalisme
alors attention la plupart du temps le
cul berlin 10 mhz que vous verrez un
spectacle est une simulation un enrobage
qui va permettre d' habiller de
justifier le tour néanmoins rien ne vous
empêche d'essayer de vous y entraîner
dans la vie courante pour le plaisir
d'essayer d'écouter les micro mouvements
d'une personne comment c'est ce que nous
allons voir
expérience une mise aux vies qu'on va
parler de cul berland 10 mhz tu connais
ce gros mot pardon le cubain en 10 mhz
alors te parle pas comme ça déjà là
merci jacques magne avait cueilli cela
c'est un peu bizarre je suis moins huit
je connais pas ce n'est pas un gros mot
c'est un nom savant en tout cas je me
demande s'ils n'ont pas trouvé ce nom
pour que ça fasse ça avant ok c'est la
lecture des micromouvements musculaire
d'accord l'art d'interpréter les micro
mouvements musculaires d'un grand débat
est ce que ça existe est-ce que ça
n'existe pas en réalité il ya beaucoup
de magiciens ou de mentalist qui le font
sur scène attention spoiler alert en
général ce n'est qu'un l'enrobage qu'on
va utiliser pour cacher ce qu'on fait
réellement moi je vois ça devient autre
prétexte mais je connais je moi je
connais personne en tout cas
personnellement qui va vraiment prendre
le risque sur scène de monter une grosse
partie de son spectacle la lecture nous
vaincrons musculaire néanmoins ça veut
pas dire que ça n'existe pas parce que
du coup quand tu t'aperçois que souvent
des magiciens ou les mentalistes qui
disent s'en servir sur scène ne s'en
sert pas du diable voilà ça n'existe pas
alors c'est pas si simple que ça les
réactions micro musculaire existe donc
peut-être elles sont un peu lisible
c'est que sur la main c'est alors c'est
partout sur le corps ok le meilleur
exemple que je pourrais donner c'est que
tu es à vélo oui comme ça et tu veux te
déporté un tout petit peu sur la droite
donc en fait tu vas pas faire de
mouvements tu vas pas réfléchir au
mouvement qui va faire inconsciemment tu
va envoyer des micromouvements qui vont
faire que tu vas changer ta trajectoire
qui avait d'ailleurs un tour de magie
qui avaient été construits ou en fait
c'était assez couillu le magicien
mettait des cartes comme ça sur la table
il donnait un pendule à une personne et
donc les cartes étaient face visible
deviez vous pensez à une carte pass et
le pendule au dessus et vous verrez
quand vous serez au dessus de votre
carte le pendule va tourner il insistait
tellement sur ce point de détail que les
gens pendule se mettaient à tourner mais
parce que la personne penser qu'il
allait se mettre à tourner à l'endroit
exact est bien foutu et je vais te faire
voir comment on peut faire d'ailleurs
qu'on va prendre quatre cartes au hasard
la ja quatre tartes qui s'y passe de
13,4 de pyxis de pique et 7 de pique je
te demander de mettre ta main comme ça
de replier de doigts par en dessous et
entre 10 mai d'attribuer une carte par
doit au dessus et tu te dis le set de
pixels douala le 6 de pics et là le
cadre de kiki silas de trappistes je te
demandais choisir une carte dans ta tête
et de te concentrer toujours sur le
doigt qui correspond à cette carte rock
ok donc tu te concentres sur le doigt
qui correspond à la carte que tu as
choisi suis d'accord donc tu as choisi
l'as de trèfle c'est correct tout ça oui
alors comment j'ai su juste avec la
pression sur tes doigts la pression
était légèrement plus forte j'entends
petit doigt alors s'ajouter aux vies
légèrement plus forte c'est vraiment pas
grand-chose faut s'entraîner tu vois
c'est comme pour tout pour le faire mais
ça c'est pour moi la meilleure
démonstration de regarde comment ça se
passe et ouf on peut refaire on peut le
b tu peut même le faire sur moi donc tu
prends le temps d'appuyer sur des lois
je jouerai le jeu c'est à dire je vais
pas retenir pour te faire plaisir ou
être plus mou pour faire carrière je
vais du soleil je vais le faire au
naturel je pense à une carte je me
concentre sur le doigt qui correspond à
cette carte et tu peux essayer
d'apprécier
geste et le site de pique
donc la première shakhtar
ne peut plus d'accord ok vas 0 fait le
jeu change et des cartes ou partie
je serai pas il faut que j'ai pu un peu
quoi que j'appellerais ouais tu en fais
tu peux jouer de tout ce que tu vas
chercher sais pas si c'est vraiment plus
dur on passe et lequel ne réagit pas
vraiment pareil que les autres ok s'il
ya une vraie différence juste en quoi il
faut que je me concentre ok
[Musique]
désiré le cadre des pics exactement
c'était quoi plus raide ouest un peu
tout qui a bougé ces rames en suivant ça
se sent un peu et puis après tu peux
augmenter la difficulté en rajoutant une
cinquième cas oui et puis après tu peux
mettre deux fois ci gerhardt avec l'aîné
les dix doigts et c'est après les deux
pieds ça marche ou ça marche très très
bien à ça marche mieux même alors le pô
le problème du cube l'irlande isme c'est
un peu le même problème que le
pickpocket isme car que le pickpocket
isme du petit entraîné que si tu
prévient pas l'autre ce que tu peux pas
dire je vais m'entraîner à voler
tellement de sens que tu le sens tu es
tu me dis si tu sens quelque chose ou
pas la personne est concentré dessus
donc je suis en tout cas pas tant que le
cube et randy c'est un autre problème
mais qui se rejoint quand même dire que
quand tu veux entraîner tu vas
t'entraîner sur tes potes et ta famille
et tu vas dire ok je vais essayer je
mette plein de cartes et je vais essayer
de retrouver ta carte dedans est tout en
lisant les microrégions musculaire donc
c'est le comprend au premier si tu rates
comme c'était peut-être famille ils vont
sûrement se [ __ ] de toi ok et ça c'est
désagréable et à cause de l'égo en fait
tu t'entraînes pas mais tu as beau leur
dire c'est pas un tour de magie je veux
montrer un truc ils sont un peu content
que tu trouves pas et du coup ça peut
être bloquée donc il ya un truc qui est
très malin à faire c'est ce que je vais
faire maintenant je te l'expliquera près
parce que sinon ça peut s'entraîner ce
soit mais non non je vais m'entraîner
sur toi et je vais te faire voir comment
donc tu choisis tu choisis une carte
celle que tu veux tu la regardes tu la
retient et tu l'as fait voir à tout le
monde et même quelqu'un de l'équipe la
retient on sait jamais si tu lis jamais
tu l'oubliés c'est bon tu l'armée dans
l'éventail on va prendre une quinzaine
de cartes en espérant que ce soit dans
et la fin je m'arrêterai sur une carte
et si elle n'est pas dedans on reprend
15 cartes etc etc donc on va en vendre 5
6 7
si même pourquoi pas un petit peu du
début un petit peu du milieu aussi chez
puis s'il augmente à y aller jusqu au
milieu
ça devrait suffire ont tout ça pour
pâques et d'un nice
en temps normal des cartes devraient
être dedans mais en vain
je te fais la prise classique du cul
berlin 10 mhz donc deux doigts de doit
se suffire c'est bien toujours qu'on me
lis qu'on a pu pas trop fort le but ce
n'est pas de prendre le pouls mais bien
de sentir les tendons petite réaction à
l'intérieur et on passe comme ça la main
au dessus du jeu toi chaque fois que
j'aurai la main sur ta carte tu te dira
stop dans ta tête ok ok très bon et moi
je vais essayer de sentir des choses
preuve en est que je vais fermer les
yeux à partir de maintenant
donc là j'ai une résistance et après sa
relaxe donc je vais enlever ce qui n est
en effet pas ta carte si tant est
qu'elle se dit
que c'est dans cette zone je vais étaler
un petit peu parce que ça me fait à peu
près pareil cas c'est pareil on a fait
ça ralentit vraiment au milieu
intéressant
ok alors là il ya une autre technique
qui existe c'est bluffant c'est moi je
passe ma main
et toi tu dis stop dans ta tête quand je
suis au dessus de tome 2 de ta carte
pratique assez marrant c'est que c'est à
peu près les mêmes réactions
topic bravo 9 de pie-ix de piques merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup
c'est impressionnant mais alors
attention c'est aussi impressionnant que
c'était truqué haha tu savais déjà que
c'était le 9 jeudi savait déjà que
c'était le note le pic absolument on m'a
traité un tour de magie tu t'es entraîné
en même temps au cube et ralentissent
mona tu viens de tout résumer c'est à
dire que comme le truc qui est un peu
désagréable c'est que quand quand on
fait ça sur ses amis ou donc sa famille
on peut se moquer toi et tu sais tu peux
te faire un truc très simple tu
t'inspires des magiciens tu fais un tour
de magie une fois que tu connais la
carte tu dis maintenant je ferme les
yeux comme ça je vois vraiment pas ce
qui se passe si je sais plus vraiment
aussi et je m'entraîne à le faire à tout
moment tu pourras te rattraper parce que
quand tu vas ouvrir les yeux tu verras
ou et sa carte et tu peux très bien dire
si tu l'a éjecté pour rien tu peux très
bien dire attends que je vais leur
mettre celle-ci parce que je veux
vérifier un truc et ça te permet d'être
sur pied en fait tu vas pas abîmer ton
égo et tu pourra s'entraîner en revanche
que tu fais toi derrière c'est que tu
t'entraînes un sens si tu t'entraînes un
truc exactement le petit tour de magie
très simple que je montais c'est alors
vous n'allez pas faire un carton avec ce
tour de magie mais c'est juste une
astuce simple j'ai mis de côté toutes
les rouges enquête que j'avais toutes
les noirs tu vas tu sais à peu près 6 et
une rouge noir je t'ai fait piocher dans
le dessus du paquet ou d'afficher la
carte pour l'été succès de noir et après
j'ai un éventail et par le bas et
j'étais dire mais le dans l'éventail
jouer dans le rouge et donc quand j'ai
choisi mes cartes j'ai fait alors je
vais en prendre une quinzaine ici et là
j'ai su quelle carte était la tienne
j'ai mis là j'ai mélangé avec d'autres
cartes de la moitié de faire juger
quelqu'un pour partir du coup tu as pu
voir en fait tous savaient que les
albanais très bien d'un entraînement au
tube erland isma charles ridoré oui
super vachement utile à une fois qu
berland disent mon q bert landis mme
hubert landier passer à la suite
le problème en voulant s'entraîner sur
ce genre de technique c'est l'ego parce
que en essayant sur vos amis ou votre
famille vous pourriez mal vivre le fait
qu'il soit déçu que vous n'y arriviez
pas voir kylie se moque un petit peu de
vous une bonne astuce est de faire comme
les magiciens sur scène vous faites un
tour de magie de votre choix une fois
que vous connaissez la carte vous
essayez quand même la petite technique
de cul berlin 10 mhz pour voir si vous
auriez ressenti quelque chose de spécial
ou pas au fait le partenaire du jour
aujourd'hui exceptionnellement ses
montres aujourd'hui pas de blague parce
que j'ai une bonne info à vous donner
mon spectacle reprend non mais alors on
savait pas trop comment vous en parler
non pas qu'on n'a pas le droit d'en
parler non on a le droit d'en parler
loïc que mon spectacle reprendre non
c'est juste bon en fait on voulait le
dire pour de vrai quoi mon spectacle
reprend parce que je sais pas si vous
avez fait hier durant un an et demi à
hulk au vide et le spectacle était à
l'arrêt sauf que ce spectacle qui lui
restait plus que six mois tournait donc
il me reste c'est six mois tournait à
faire et là tu as compris ça reprend ça
reprend comme disent les rochelais
d'ailleurs je serai à la rochelle en
janvier 2022 donc là je reprends le
spectacle habré sur
sa nuque 79 à montoir de bretagne dans
le 44 je vais partout où je ne suis pas
passé plus de deux fois donc par exemple
je reviendrai pas à marseille j'ai
beaucoup passé à marseille mais je vais
passer à toulouse je reviendrai pas à
mulhouse par exemple parce que je suis
déjà beaucoup passé à mulhouse et à
strasbourg mais je vais revenir à
bordeaux aussi et puis à tours et puis à
nantes et puis à lyon et puis un petit
peu partout en france je compte sur vous
vous avez un lien dans la description
pour les infos les réservations et où
les questions que vous risquez de vous
poser c'est est ce que tu viens en
belgique oui est ce que tu viens suisse
oui est ce que tu viens au canada ça va
dépendre du comics a toujours parce que
c'est pas faux c'est pas le même pays
même si des fois on parle la même langue
autre question est-ce que vous brillez
anciens billets pour ces dates là
restent valables la réponse est oui
est-ce qu'on se voit toujours à la fin
des spectacles en dédicace la réponse
est oui donc si vous n'avez pas vu
singularité spectacle de mentalisme
d'humour qui met là silence et tout ça
je n'aime voir ça me fera très plaisir
tant que vous m'aurez pas vu sur scène
vous serez pas qu'il oeuvrait fabien moi
je viens de la scène la base est celle
avons passé au moins une bonne soirée ça
dure environ deux heures et si vous avez
déjà vu le spectacle ne le ratez pas le
zénith de paris le 11 décembre on l'a
reportée deux fois là ça joue c'est sûr
c'est la dernière dernière du spectacle
et du coup j'ai prévu pas mal de
surprises il y aura la captation en plus
tu viendras salut tu viendras un
attendant il faut toujours un témoignage
un témoignage sincère de gens qui sont
venus sincèrement bonjour que qui êtes
vous monsieur qui passaient dans la rue
je suis un passant dans la rue exact
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu le
spectacle de fabien olicard non mais
j'aimerais beaucoup n'en tue la joe
louis fois à wind on l'a vu plein de
fois ci alors non je suis jeté un
passant dans la rue et honnête on a dit
oui par de manquer alors bonjour bonjour
est ce que vous avez déjà vu le
spectacle de fabien olicard oui vous
l'avez vu combien de fois 4 x 3 watts a
fait l'olympia la scène musicale tu
étais là ali al hilawi tu étais là de la
tour eiffel
mais tu vois et j'ai envie d'y retourner
est ce que vous pourriez le jouer à sa
place du coup à bord non non pas parce
que je suis jeune et je pense qu'elles
veulent faut admettre que fabien peut le
faire à vis à vis de moi qu'il faut que
je vous invite à venir le voir et moi je
vous invite il vous paye les places vous
prenez vos places et vous envoyez votre
ticket à l'oic qui vous remboursera une
fois que vous l'aurez prise évidemment
parce que loïc viennent le dire il vous
est un double aveugle et merci beaucoup
mais on ne sait rien rajouté que tu ne
pourras pas annulé
il les invite quoi c'est waou le la
générosité du gal
du vrai nom tic-tac-toe le morpion est
un jeu de trois cas sur trois cases qui
à l'origine n'avait pas de limites les
historiens ont même retrouvé une version
de ce jeu chez les romains un siècle
avant notre ère mais est il possible de
ne jamais perdre à ce jeu la réponse est
oui et même de gagner
ludo oui tu aimes les morpions j'adore
lesquels jack sort tout s'est vraiment
fait qu'il suivra je vais juste devant
venturi vais régulièrement du coup ça
chez un tic-tac-toe oui tout à fait tic
tac toe était plutôt rond ou croit
en gros tu sais où je vais pas de
préférence mais pourquoi pas et je crois
que t'as pas de préférence mais tu
prenais elle profite encore près de toi
tu veux commencer où je commence à c'est
la question piège
écoute je commence je vais commencer
alors je t'invite à faire tes croix et à
mettre à côté un petit 1 de tout savoir
moi ceux conservés dans des tailles et
le truc ouais ok c'est parti très bien
ok toi tu commence ici intéressant
tubage de santis est un peu atypique
je te prends le centre oisive asie les i
c'est un plaisir
et
à baho s'il vous plaît
sans surprise bien sûr je viens blocs
béton groupe fais toi plaisir je vais
faire les mêmes là où ça ne te dérange
pas et puis là je gagne ma foi on
termine en jouant pour rien puisqu'on
peut pas gagner puisqu'on peut pas
gagner
alors là j'ai utilisé une stratégie
simple que je vais expliquer tout à
l'heure qui permet de ne jamais perdre
quand l'autre commence pour forcer le
match nul ok très peu de chances de
gagner si on ne commence pas d'accord
mais maintenant c'est à moi de commencer
à la je vais prendre tarifs d'asile
n'ont pas spécialement mais
j'avais hésité à lisier monsieur toi
j'avais dit à commencer par la voit pas
je vais pas te faire un match nul en a
ainsi tu peux donc que tu joues quand il
faut se connaître sa technique du match
nul puisque ce n'est pas le cas mais
faut que tu joue vraiment comme tories
merci de m'offrir cette belle victoire
ah bah oui
donc il n'avait pas tellement le choix
alors au final bas et non mais là il
constitue jamais là pourquoi pas toi tu
vas gagner ici est ce qui permet de
mettre ici la technique pour gagner à
tous les coups alors ça c'est une
technique quand tu commences tu joues tu
commence toujours par un coin ok alors
en fait les techniques que je vais vous
donner après dans la partie suivante
elles permettent de ne jamais perdre
c'est pas forcément de toujours gagner
mais déjà de ne jamais perdre tu as plus
de chances de gagner ni quand c'est toi
qui commence si tu commences par un coin
et que quelqu'un joue au centre tu fais
on appelle ça la ligne xo ou oxo ça va
permettre de favoriser le nombre de
coups possibles ou sa double il ya assez
peu de choses en fait tu aurais pu faire
des choses pour pas que j'aboutis ce à
la double possibilité que la seule
manière de gagner au morpion sauf
l'inattention de l'adversaire mais si
toi tu veux attaquer pour essayer de
faire une ligne quelque part quoi qu'il
arrive je gagne ça veut dire qu'il ya
pas des compétitions
6 mondial de tic-tac-toe qua non alors
dites sera le vrai morpion à la base
quand il a été inventé donc par les
romains
un siècle avant notre ère en -100 il
n'avait pas de limites c'est nous qui
avons condensé ça c'est une variante en
fait le temps cas sur trois sur trois
qu'elle en fait c'était beaucoup plus
long et ce n'était pas forcément les
lignes entières et c'est ça devient
presque comme un jeu de goût puissant
6-4 2-6 en ce qui a trait aux six sites
en plastique déjà est vraiment concret
en avant plus fort ça on allait la
dernière attaque a commencé pas j'aurais
dû te dire le croiser bas à quoi
je
ressemblais balle au centre
ok pas essayer d'appliquer la technique
c'est pas grave dit j'ai complètement
zappé ok on va vers quoi un match nul et
lin du coup on va au niveau de toute
manière en vrai quoi qu'il arrive une
fois que tu connais des techniques
tu vas tu peux forcer le trop nuls trois
parties de match nul n'était pas de
gagner une battue good game
boy game évidemment j'ai triché j'ai
même si l'autriche est toujours magique
j'ai triché tous les côtés entre guinée
j'ai pas tout les avec le détail de
toutes les techniques parce que t'as pas
de connoter donc juste les données sur
vous c'est pas piéger de connoter mais
cette table je peux l'emporter c'est le
dernier épisode de la saison ce vote
n'est par contre vous je vous
l'expliquais maintenant
comme vous l'avez vu le but est d'abord
de ne pas perdre en disant à minima le
match nul et si possible en gagnant si
vous commencez ne se dit pas attiré par
le centre mais au contraire viser un
coin l'être humain est imprévisible
votre adversaire va viser le centre et
là vous mettez de nouveau votre cou dans
le coin opposé
cette technique va favoriser
l'apparition pour vous d'un double coup
que votre adversaire ne pourra pas
contré et s'il joue ailleurs qu'au
centre son premier coup alors vous allez
gagner automatiquement en mettant votre
deuxième coup dans un coin qui laissera
une case vide entre lui et votre premier
coup si votre adversaire commence vous
pourrez faire match nul s'il commence
par un coin répliqué directement au
centre en ne jouant jamais les bords
sauf si c'est pour contrer l'un de ses
coûts évidemment s'ils commencent au
centre enchaîné par un point puis contré
tous ses coups vous ne perdrez jamais
dans ce c'est à vous nous allons tester
votre et notre capacité à être
prévisible
c'est parti pour le cdh avouons le c'est
à vous c'est toujours un truc que tu vas
faire c'est une émission télé gisent
vont faire ce qu c'est vrai
que non mais nous ça
s'est un peu avoue maintenant au qatar
va pas le titre complet c'est ça quand
tu passes un petit peu profitez-en du
coup comme on regarde si on est
prévisibles ou pas on va le faire un
petit peu sur l'esprit maintenant
imagine que ça c'est un immense bac à
sable ok ok donc beaucoup plus grand des
vallées chez abc et puis avec du sable
blanc très très blanc ça marche il ya un
trésor qui a été enterrée proxy je vais
te demander de faire une croix là où tu
penses qu'il est enterré d'accord mais
évidemment j'en ai aucune idée géant n'a
aucune idée pour le moment mais serait
bien au centre ça me paraît trop simple
sur cette île très carré d'as est il
seul dessein paraît trop simple donc je
pense qu'ils sont allés l'enfouir un peu
genre donne un truc un peu genre ici
nous souvent les cartes de pirates ces
salariés repris des petits traits donc
toi tu penses qu'il est enterré là est
ce que vous vous lui auriez mis dans un
coin aussi je vous laisse me dire dans
les commentaires en tout cas oui on est
prévisibles est ce que la grande
majorité des personnes de même dans les
coins en priorité et après un peu
dispersé évidemment on a même gardé ceux
qui sont complètement à côté donc j'ai
les gros pâté sûr quand même dans les
coins et en fonction de commencer mais
toi tu vois tes pas dans le coin le plus
chargé tu es plutôt dans le coin le
moins chargé mais en fait il ya c'est
marrant d'ailleurs c'est de voir que au
final on a un immense x ça la faim est
une croix qui est une croix de delacroix
que tu as fait toi ici donc oui on est
un peu prévisibles pourquoi parce qu'on
cherche toujours à interpréter et
rationaliser notre réflexe mental mais
le réflexe mental est venue avant et toi
c'est marrant parce que tu savais où tu
voulais faire et juste après tu as fait
attends je vais vous expliquer quand
même mon raisonnement mais dis toi que
ton raisonnement il est venu à
posteriori il ya un truc qui est très
marrant à voir qui marche bien aussi
c'est si je fais ça
tu es ce que toi tu lis actuellement
clairement moi je viens de biche polir 1
13 mai julien d et vous vous lisez quoi
1,13 ou un bep ludovic b normal quoi tu
es mais c'est vrai que si je fais ça à
côté
ça me permet de moi te faire interpréter
ça comme j'en ai envie tout à fait la c1
13 pour toi mais par contre si je fais
ça dans la colonne
forcément c'est un certain que sur ans
que tu lis et 1b et ça ça montre aussi
notre côté prévisible c'est à dire que
si on a quelque chose de très ambigu tu
peux lui donner du sens à posteriori
c'est à dire je peux te présenter un
choix très ambigu tu vois on appelle ça
aussi un choix de magicien dans le
mentalisme et puis une fois que tu as
fait ce choix là je vais coller un
élément à côté de ton choix pour dire
oui exactement c'est exactement ça que
je voulais te dire depuis le déplacement
c'était un 13e grand route ça dépend ce
que tu ressens exactement donc en fait
la ccc un petit jeu mais qui permet
d'extrapoler de se dire faut faire gaffe
au départ à ce que les données à soit
toujours bien clair et si elles sont pas
claires de demandé de la clarté à la
d'autres personnes ou comme toi si ça
avait été quelque chose à enjeu et pas
juste un jeu comme ça tu peux me dire
oui à temps qu'est ce que je vois il
faut que je voie d'être un dessin un
chiffre précise moi ce que tu es ce que
tu me demande tu vois ce que je veux
dire donc voilà ça c'est très
intéressant pour pas vous faire avoir
dans les réflexes manteau conditionné
alors y en a un qui est plutôt connue on
va quand même le tester sur toi si tu me
connais tu hésites pas me le dire je
vais te demander d'abord de faire des
opérations simples et après je te prends
je te posera une question je veux une
réponse à ses réflexes à cette question
qui accueille donc de plus de 4 puisque
ça va quatre mois un tu veux te vers 3
ok 5,3 accepte
1-8-7 +5 est toujours besoin de visa
c'est plus un rêve tous est un outil est
une couleur oui un marteau et bleu c'est
pas mal mais c'est pas mal du tout un
petit bug qui a eu le marteau dites moi
dans les commentaires et qui a dit rouge
au lieu de bleu dit moins dans les
commentaires tu connais c'est ça ou pas
non pas du tout quand des jeunes
chirurgiens fait mes calculs sont déjà
je
vais t'expliquer tout processus de ça
donc l'extrême majorité des personnes
vont répondre marteau rouge ok donc tu
peux l'essayer dans ton entourage
c'est vrai j'ai dit j'ai dit quoi m
marteau bleus à musique donc marteau
rouge c'est l'écrasante majorité on a
tendance à dire plus de 90 % mais j'ai
jamais trouvé d'études qui montrent sa
part contre mon expérience montre que
oui c'est l'extrême majorité marteau
rouge et après en choix secondaire
d'outils après le marteau via le
tournevis et il est sur la couleur après
le rouge bien le bleu donc c'était pas
c'était pas si à côté que ça pour toi
mais c'est peut-être aussi parce que
c'était à la fois c'est ce qu'on se
représente le plus communément dans un
marteau fall dans les outils pendant dès
que l'on doit illustrer les outils
accuse le marteau ou tournevis parce que
s'ils se conservent plus peut-être le
rouge et le bleu c'est aussi des
couleurs qu'on vienne qui nous viennent
le plus souvent parce que c'est celle
qu'on voit le plus ne serait-ce que j'en
parle le robinet d'eau chaude ou froide
comme cela s'est passé à peu près ça
pour la couleur alors pour l'outil c'est
que aussi ça vient même de l'enfant
c'est à dire que depuis toujours le
premier outil avec qui tu as été en
contact ces impacts au stade directement
taper avec quelque chose en tout cas tu
vois et on a l'impression que bricoler
c'est d'abord tapé et après sévices et
creuse etc mais que s'est-il d'abord
quelque chose que vous vous plus primé
en fait dans la vie tu es et pour la
couleur c'est pareil c'est les primaires
depuis petit on a appris que le rouge
est important donc toute la
signalisation sont en rouge tout ce qui
est dangereux et en rouge à l'école on
te corriger en rouge la couleur de
l'amour celle rouge le danger le rouge
le ton sang et rouge donc en fait c'est
une couleur très présente et honte à
presque appris que une couleur c'est
rouge ou autre chose c'est d'abord rouge
tu vois la couleur elle sait pas donc
quand on conditionné comme ça exactement
quand on sature ton cerveau on va dire
analytique rationnel avec des calculs
simples idiot à tanger supporter occuper
l'esprit serein plus simple
s'il finit par un set par cinq tours a
toujours le bug qui a eu la wii c'est
pour ça que je le fais à chaque fois et
une fois que la personne est en train de
vraiment raisonnée hausse est plus
simple c'est là que tu sais que ta
saturer son cerveau analytique et c'est
là tu lui dis la question donne moi un
outil une couleur effet pas comme moi
parce que des fois j'ai dit donne moi un
outil et du rouge
également un outil est une couleur et
dans l'extrême majorité des 14 mars
rouge mais vraiment je t'invite ldc ici
un taux oui je le sais ce soir ou demain
est pareil essayez le sur des personnes
de votre entourage alors c'est je dire
une phrase à la con mais c'est connu
pour ceux qui connaissent ceux qui
connaissent on ira je connaissais depuis
super longtemps mais en fait en réalité
moi je j'en fait j'en parle de
régulièrement en vidéo tous les 2-3 ans
et j'ai jamais quelqu'un qui me dit on
va être nous en a déjà parlé de ça
s'oublie puisque ça ça c'est intéressant
et ça montre aussi qu'on est prévisible
là dessus dire que dans des situations
soient de stress soit on a une capacité
notre raisonnement qui est saturé on va
avoir l'impression de faire des choix
librement
et parce que on va au plus simple est ce
qui nous arrive direct à l'esprit comme
exacts et et c'est quelque chose qu'on
peut très bien utiliser en marketing en
politique dans les médias pour amener
quelqu'un a pensé assez logiquement à
quelque chose alors qu'elle s'est sentie
complètement libre de choisir ceux qui
utilisent et d'ailleurs c'est utilisé ou
pas moi je mets du conditionnel j'ai par
exemple que là tout de suite par contre
c'est vraiment il ya un bouquin qui
s'appelle lentilles de la manipulation
oui je vais pas vraiment qu'il en parle
très bien excessivement bien voilà des
petites choses en tout cas qui montre
qu'on est plus ou moins prévisibles
complètement mais que du coup si tu
tentes mêmes techniques sur une extrême
majorité de personnes ça fonctionne
tiens d'ailleurs à les derniers petits
tests c'est pour mon plaisir personnel
tu vas penser à un nombre à deux
chiffres
d'accord dans les deux chiffres sont un
père mais différents l'un de l'autre les
deux dom être un père ouais mais
différemment d'autres ok très bien à
quoi tu penses 35 à 35 oui je l'avais
barré parce que j'hésitais avec 37 trop
bas oui oui bah oui on va l'expliquer du
coup comment tu as eu 35 je vais choisir
n'importe quoi d'autre oui en vrai
absolument parce qu'au début j'étais sur
23 et après tu as dis ouais mais ça doit
être les deux doivent être un père donc
je suis bête 33 après tu as dis ouais
non mais ils doivent être différent le
coup j'ai pris 35 ans fait comme je t'ai
dit un nombre à deux chiffres des parts
a tendance à penser à quelque chose qui
est dans la vingtaine ok c'est induit
c'est comme ça tu va se passer bas et
ensuite je te donne les règles au fur et
à mesure je te dis mais attention ces
deux chiffres doivent être un père serre
ça c'est donc tu vas aux impairs le plus
proche la trentaine et différents l'un
de l'autre donc en général sur le un
père suivant 35 ou alors 37 et ça c'est
un vrai petit truc d'escrocs mentalist
est ce que tu vois si les deux
d'embarras et humer l'autre et puis
après toi tu as ta mémoire sélective
c'est génial qui qui va faire son
travail et dans deux jours tu raconteras
tout le monde que j'ai écrit que 35 que
tu te souviens plus qui régirait tout le
monde s'était gaussé
nous avons tous l'illusion d'être
terriblement unique c'est ce qui nous
rend terriblement prévisible d'ailleurs
je mentirais si je vous disais que je
n'exploite pas ce principe dans mes
spectacles de mentalisme les expériences
que nous venons de voir proviennent de
l'étude des stéréotypes du docteur marx
paris en 2000 dans ce psycho logic of
the sight chic
et oui notre corps à des réflexes qui
dépasse notre raison eu aussi des
limitations mais comme nous avons une
certaine méconnaissance de tout ça nous
pensons tout contrôler mais sa naïve de
notre part et ça peut même amener un
manipulateur à exploiter ses prévisions
assez simplement
on a vu que l'esprit était prévisible
oui on est surtout le mien de quand on
joue on est prévisibles sur plein de
choses non pas tant le tient alors j'ai
trouvé ça plutôt pas mal mais en fait ça
ok c'est marrant c'est que même si on
connaît des trucs qui explique qu on est
prévisibles on se fait avoir quand même
et j'ai emmené toujours prévisibles quoi
est ce que le corps les c'est une
question je pense que oui oui encore et
prévisible par pas mal de choses par des
choses qui séduit sur un possible
affaire où des choses parfois qu'il fait
par réflexe ou des choses qu'on connaît
mal et là on va avoir des choses qu'on
connaît mal premier test je vais te
demander de faire ceci sur la table donc
tu remplis le majeur tu poses tous les
autres doigts et tu plaque l'ensemble je
crois que pourraient pas lever suis là
et bien on va voir cette petite lève le
pouce we luv l'index oui lève le petit
doigt lève le majeur voilà sans décoller
c'est pas très frustrant regardez vous
regardez touche pas
et tu claques
est ce que ça te vénère pas un peu au
fond de toi ne pas contrôler ton corps
un peu c'est fou ou pas mais ça je
connaissais ça y est tu vois ça ça fait
partie des trucs que qui montre que la
méconnaissance de quelque chose peut te
rendre prévisible en gros ça c'est un
truc qui à une époque a servi les
charlatans tu vas a montré qu'ils
avaient des capacités à bloquer des
parties ton corps ou des choses comme ça
parce que tu as une méconnaissance du
corps donc là le côté prévisible c'est
juste dans le côté qu'est-ce qu'on peut
manipuler quand on sait quelque chose
que ton corps va faire ou ne pas faire
que les autres et que toi tu sais pas
d'ailleurs va voir petitesse de
suggestions tout de suite je te
demandais de croiser comme ceci tu vois
et d'avoir des deux doigts jours ok tu
te mets à hauteur de moi comme ça bien
un droit ou bien droit comme ça et tu
vas écarté tes doigts comme ça bien
raide en les écartant et tu vas juste
regarder l'espace entre les doigts et je
vais vie c'est pour essayer de faire en
sorte qu'ils se rapprochent c'est au fur
et à mesure ils vont se rapprocher comme
ça de plus en plus de plus en plus de
plus en plus et plus je serre la vis
fort et plus ils vont se rapprocher l'un
de l'autre et encore et un but en or et
encore et encore et encore et on va
arrêter là c'est dingue la refermer de
la moitié quand même oui ses moves est
très rapide alors hypnose ou
prévision des réactions de ton corps où
j'ai pas des muscles c'est solide
évidemment j'en ai marre ça c'est pas
tout à fait compris en réalité à bien ta
blague c'est exactement ça c'est à dire
que si je te vends ça comme une
suggestion tu vas avoir l'impression que
ça l'est parce que tu as une
confirmation de ce que j'ai dit en fait
en réalité la seule chose qui était
prévisible c'est que ça c'est pas une
position naturelle bah ouais donc tes
muscles fatigue et donc au fur et à
mesure et revient dans la position qui
gît qui est la moins dure à tenir à
savoir celle ci j'avais raison
finalement c'est avait complètement
raison maintenant tu vas trop longtemps
et c'est le fait qu'on sert comme ça et
que en fait d'ailleurs le meilleur truc
que rêver qui aurait pu donner le
premier rallye c'est à dire aux poteaux
départ quand je t'ai dit croise et mes
doigts comme ça tu t'es mis comme ça tu
t'es pas mis comme ça écart avait en
fait écarter c'était un effort personnes
sauvées comme ça l'éléphant on veut pas
le tenir éternellement donc voilà ça
c'est des tout petits trucs pour montrer
que votre corps à des réactions qui sont
prévisibles et qui peuvent servir à une
manipulation quelconque assez bien pensé
c'est comme le truc où exactement c'est
comme le tout coûte 5 mai les mains
comme ça là après on me demande de faire
ça
en pointe le doigt est en fait tu combat
oui tu arrives à confondre ton cerveau
et du coup il sait plus quel doigt levé
et quand on pointe le doigt tient une
boîte suis là que d'un autre exact une
confusion en fait tu vois parce qu'en
fait en réalité tu peux te dire tout
simplement tout ce que ton corps ne fait
pas au quotidien il n'a pas besoin de
savoir de savoir le faire du coup tu
vois tu vois comment te dire c'est un
mec comme ça tu avec jamais d'être comme
ça il n'a pas besoin de comprendre
qu'elle doit et à tel endroit ça
proprioception aléas les bousiller parce
qu'on n'a pas besoin de ça jamais cette
évolution se retient jamais comme ça
quoi ces entraves à toi par contre
regardez c'est de faire ça mais les
mains comme sarah parallèle à
l'extérieur il la main droite sur la
main gauche puis sert comme ça attention
il faut vraiment serré certes c'est un
pur de ponderach il ya trois ans tourner
à gauche 1 2 3 comme ça
et
ça lui redonne soirée
nous pourrions faire de nombreux tests
sur les réflexes et les automatismes du
corps qui le rendent si prévisible dans
un prochain matière grise par exemple
mais celui ci comme on pouvait le
prévoir et le dernier le dernier de la
saison une saison un peu bizarre de onze
numéros qui a duré presque deux ans j'ai
pu créer ce format la première fois car
j'avais trouvé un partenaire mais j'aime
tellement ce programme que j'ai voulu
continuer alors que bon le coup d'un
matière grise me demande un gros
investissement
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que nous
faisions un épisode tous les deux mois
en fait j'aime tellement ce programme
que j'ai voulu en faire ensuite un par
mois ce qui explique aussi des sponsors
sur les vidéos casse tête pour financer
matière grise cabinet curieuse etc mais
deux formats préféré qui rapporte 10
fois moins que ce qui coûte à produire
alors merci à vous deux se tient ces
formats en les regardant tout simplement
la question est qui est chaud pour une
saison 2 un épisode par mois pendant un
an vous vous doutez que moi ça me
chauffe l'équipe ça vous chauffe
grosse modise moi j'ai besoin de savoir
si vous serez au rendez vous vous pouvez
me le dire en lit quand cette vidéo en
commentant mais aussi en partageant les
épisodes que vous avez aimé de matière
grise et tout ça ça me permettra d'aller
chercher des financements pour la saison
merci à tous les participants à toute
l'équipe à fannie et jérémie à la
production à loïc à la réalisation avec
toute son équipe est bien sûr à ludovic
b n'hésitez pas à découvrir ces vidéos
le lien est dans la description c'est
tous les dimanches à 10h c'est un vrai
bonheur vous pouvez partager cette vidéo
lalique et et vous abonner gratuitement
à cette chaîne si cette série vous plaît
vous avez également tous les épisodes
dans la description les dix épisodes en
entier via une clé 10 alors est ce que
vous voulez le suit est ce qu'on aura de
nouvelles idées pour vous surprendre
dans ce format est ce qu'on pourra
continuer l'aventuré nous aurons la
réponse à tout cela et bien plus dans la
prochaine saison de matière grise
j'espère à très bientôt ciao